I've also heard you talk about why it's
unpopular for men to be seen as stoic
anymore what's your insight though
well again yeah
um a stoic man is a toxic man in the
minds of Hollywood writers whereas I see
it as like a necessary
um survival skill really throughout most
of human history like you you can't have
everyone uh be high strung emotional
idiots who just go to PCS the moment
like things start going wrong there
needs to be stoic people who can deal
with problems
um logically and don't complain all the
time about things you know it's
people used to live Hard lives I guess
that's the the point I'm making previous
generations would be shocked and
appalled by how easy we have it now but
they they used to struggle and they used
to have to put up with a lot of hardship
and you develop stoicism as a result of
that that's what allowed you to deal
with it because you couldn't sit and
complain all the time because there was
no one to complain to you had to get on
and do things
um we don't live in that world now and
so that idea of stoicism the stoic man
um who who gets things done and who
doesn't complain about it
um
that is seen as a toxic relic of a
different time and I think particularly
because of the the writers that you have
you've either got women
now in Hollywood
um who don't who are threatened by that
or you have effeminate men who've never
endured hardship uh who are envious of
that and so either side wants to destroy
it and get rid of it and mock it because
they don't understand it
um and so that's yeah that's what you
have now you don't get stoic male
characters they have to be constantly
joking they have to be constantly like
doing the the goofy um self-conscious
ironic humor about themselves they
usually have to mess things up like it's
just uh I don't know about you I just
that's not the kind of men that I've
known in my entire life like they they
don't act like that that's a caricature
Hollywood version of what a man
is meant to act like
come up with
it's not accurate the way that women act
either most of the women that I know
especially the ones that I respect and
admire can deal with difficult things
they can go through exactly
and it's not it's not a unique yeah it's
not a uniquely male trait uh in the
slightest and you know it's not that uh
women would be expected to to be you
know super feminine and and uh you know
hyper emotional about everything not at
all
um there's usually a little bit of
granular sort of variation between them
for sure
um but again their idea of like writing
a strong female character now is just
someone who's a total who is
like super aggressive super domineering
wins every argument
never gets challenged on anything
um doesn't have any compassion or
anything for for other people uh again
that's that's not really how I've known
women to act
you use this really good example of the
animated Mulan movie compared with the
live-action remake that they did and in
the original one the girl that joins
this fighting force is smaller and
doesn't have experience and needs to
work incredibly hard to overcome her
physical limitations of being physically
smaller than everybody else and she has
to use Ingenuity and different tools and
she has to be smarter and she has to
work harder and that invests you in the
character I care about her outcomes
because an Underdog Story is one that
you're always going to resonate with and
then it comes to the live-action version
which is
a girl pretends to be a guy because
there aren't enough soldiers and then is
simply better than everybody else
because of some ineffable inherent
embodied
thing like Super Chief estrogen Chi or
something and because of the estrogen
Chi it means that she can win beat
people that have been doing it for much
longer than her that have worked harder
than her she doesn't have to go through
any difficulty or any challenge apart
from people
not believing in her primarily because
of her gender
and then she can save the day like
that's not an empowering story any woman
that thinks that that's an empowering
story for your daughter to have
doesn't have the same definition of
empowerment that I do
yeah that's it's the perfect example
really of the the kind of uh ridiculous
thinking that you have now in movie
making when it comes to writing
characters like that like you say
the original gave you a good a great
message not just for little girls but
for anyone really like you might not
always be the strongest you might not be
the fastest or whatever
um but you can still Prevail through
through working hard through Ingenuity
through create creativity of those
things can can help you overcome uh
limitations
um but yeah the modern movie is
basically saying you have no limitations
you're amazing just everyone else needs
to accept how amazing you are uh it's
such a destructive message to give
people because life is meant to be about
improving yourself it's meant to be
about uh trying and feeling and picking
yourself up and doing better next time
that's that's the point of it
I learned a new word a couple of weeks
ago called fan baiting have you heard of
this
um
made a video about it in fact
did you really explain to people who
don't know what fan baiting is
so in Broad terms fan baiting is the
idea of
um we're gonna create a new TV show or
whatever it's probably going to be an
adaptation or a remake of something that
you love uh what we're going to do
though is we're going to race and or
gender swap most of the characters uh
we're gonna make a huge deal out of the
fact that we're doing that
uh and we're basically saying to the
fans of this this franchise hey we're
changing everything that you love
doesn't it make you mad don't you want
to don't you want to lash out don't you
want to criticize us go and do it do it
see what happens and that's what happens
you know people rise to the debate uh
they get mad about it inevitably some
people will go too far and they will be
genuine sexists or racist uh they'll say
things that are very inappropriate and
those people get
the those comments that they make get
caught they get captured they get uh
spread out for everyone to see by the
the actual company that's doing this the
studio and they'll say look this fan
base is toxic the only people that hate
this product are racist and sexists uh
you don't want to be like that do you
you don't want to be one of those people
you want to be a good person you want to
support the thing that we're doing don't
you support it just just go along with
it and that's it that's what it is it
shames people into supporting something
which is fundamentally it's fan
beating it beats people into
doing the thing that they want so that
they can they can trumpet it as well
we're just on the right side here and
everyone else who criticizes our product
is on the wrong side that's all it is
there is only so far that you can push
people through guilt and shame to be
able to do something it's a an
interesting analogy with some of the
issues that came up in the early 2010s
when uh 50 Shades had done really really
well as a novel and the dark romance
genre generally was taken off everything
was great but there were some concerns
that uh the kind of erotic novels that
women were buying were showing a very
competent very assertive very dominant
protagonist in the man so what they did
was they tried to replace those men on
the front cover with much more kind
gentle more agreeable less dominant men
and guess what they didn't sell well
right the heart wants what the heart
wants what can I say yeah dude your your
money and your arousal are two things
that you don't tend to give away without
actually genuinely wanting to and the
fan making things so fascinating we saw
this with ah what was that Bros boy what
was it Bros bros yeah Bros yes which I
never watched it but I know yeah yeah I
know the director basically was like you
know if you don't watch this you're a
bigot and it's like that's just mask off
like straight up it's the equivalent of
basically getting down on your knees and
begging people to watch your your show
or your teeth or your movie you know uh
it's pathetic and it's sad and it's just
it really exposed how bad that stuff was
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]